[Aplausos]
el arte de transformar un 'no' en un zig
y damas y caballeros en efecto es un
arte pero también una ciencia y
probablemente una de las personas que
más no enfrentó en su vida fue thomas
alva edison
cuando 999 veces la vida le dijo que no
podía inventar el foco sin embargo el
intento mil lo consiguió y cuando me
pongo a pensar y trato de hacer memoria
de cuando fue de las primeras veces que
la vida me dijo que no recuerdo que
cuando era chico y salir a la calle con
mis papás traslape ya que me compraban
cualquier cosa se me antojaba no y a
veces me compraba las cosas y a veces
tenía una expresión como esta y estoy
seguro que mucho que muchos de ustedes
también la vivieron sin embargo también
recuerdo que de chiquito siempre tuvo un
peculiar y particular interés por saber
cómo funcionaban las cosas y entre más
me metí a investigar y a conocer eso me
llevó a la ciencia y las matemáticas por
lo cual eventualmente decidí estudiar
ciencias de la computación en la unam y
fue ahí donde escuché el problema de los
puentes de königsberg en donde las
personas que habitaban esta ciudad
buscaban una única forma de cruzar los
siete puentes que unían a la ciudad
más de una vez por alguno de ellos
pasaron los años y nadie pudo resolver
el problema hasta que en el año 1776 un
matemático llamado leonardo el er
resolvió el problema utilizando una
estructura matemática llamada grafos
dando paso así a una nueva rama de
estudio de las matemáticas llamada la
anterior de grafos los grafos tan
simples o complejos como los veamos son
entes matemáticos que nos ayudan a
modelar y abstraer nuestra realidad para
resolver problemas y sustentar los
científicamente
y si nos ponemos a pensar al final del
día no es la vida una serie de constante
problemas sin embargo más que problemas
a mí me gusta verlos como áreas de
oportunidad áreas de mejora que podemos
trabajar para conseguir lo que queramos
y este señor es señores señoras y
señores que vemos aquí es el que
necesitamos entender para dominar el
arte de transformar uno en sí y yo lo
llamo el grafo de metas si nos pusimos a
pensar también en la vida siempre
tenemos un ojo y nos toca ir a trabajar
por él si de esta forma no nacemos con
propiedades no nacemos con dinero no nos
dimos con un coche auto o un auto último
modelo por lo cual tienes que trabajar
día a día para conseguir lo que te
propones en la vida para entender un
poquito cómo llegué a modelar esta
estructura que a mí me funcionó para
lograr mis objetivos quiero platicar una
historia y remontar me algunos años en
mi primera clase de introducción a las
ciencias de la computación una de mis
profesoras me dijo que algunos egresados
de la carrera habían trabajado en
empresas como google como amazon o
microsoft multinacionales reconocidas a
nivel mundial y yo pensé que estaba loca
como era posible que una persona como yo
de una escuela particular perdón de que
nunca había estado en una escuela
particular que toda la vida había ido en
escuelas públicas que no tenía ninguna
gracia extraordinaria iba a poder lograr
algo así y dije no es imposible
un año después fui a la final
internacional de un torneo de desarrollo
de aplicaciones móviles en santiago de
chile y conocí a una reclutadora de
dicha empresa de google y nos mostró un
vídeo que literalmente me cambió la vida
y cambió mi forma de pensar y es ese que
ven ahí en el cual contaba la historia
de 24 chilenos que saliendo de ese
torneo aplicaron para trabajar en la
empresa y se quedan y ellos decían que
las personas creían que eran un lugar
tan místico y tan inalcanzable que nunca
iban a poder llegar ahí y fue cuando
entendí por primera vez que mi maestra
no estaba loca y que era capaz de lograr
lo que me proponía si trabajaba duro por
ello y me creía capaz de hacerlo y que
creen que dice pues aplique y que cree
me pasó me rechazaron igual que el 97%
de los aplicantes me rechazaron la
primera fase
sin embargo en vez de tirar la toalla y
renunciar a mi sueño dije a ver qué voy
a hacer qué habilidades voy a
desarrollar para el mediano plazo
convertirme en ese 3% y desarrolla y
traza un plan a mediano plazo para
lograrlo de esta forma puede pasar de
ser un estudiante normal al que le
preocupaba solamente ir los viernes de
fiesta como éste a dos años y medio
después cumplir mi sueño y trabajar en
esta empresa
así es esta fue la primera pero no la
última vez que logré una gran meta sólo
con creerme capaz de hacerlo y
proponérmelo también me pasó cuando
estudié en una de las mejores
universidades del mundo el instituto de
tecnología de massachusetts y en la
universidad de nueva york
y fue ahí entonces que me di cuenta que
habían ciertos patrones y cosas que se
repetían en cada gran logro de mi vida
y luego lo vi como un problema
matemático y lo modelo con forma del
grafo de metas justamente que les
contaba entonces ahora quiero que veamos
qué son los componentes esas letras que
ven ahí que son y cómo llega a esa
conclusión este de aquí es el mismo
grafo pero viéndolo de un nivel menos
abstracto en términos más humanos y
consta básicamente de cinco pasos que
tienes que seguir en la vida para
conseguir cualquier meta que te
propongas a nivel personal profesional o
académico cualquier cosa lo puedes
lograr si te crees capaz de ello
entonces vamos a verlo el paso número
uno es encontrar tu pasión no en mi caso
fue chistoso porque yo cuando no sabía
que quería estudiar yo sólo sabía que
quería hacer mucho dinero yo quería ser
rico entonces dije pues que me deja
dinero es la política o estudiar derecho
que me deja dinero administración algo
así sin embargo me di cuenta que toda mi
vida había estado rodeado de
computadoras aprendí a leer y escribir
antes de entrar al kínder con un
programa de computadoras entonces fue un
poco
darme cuenta de que era bueno para hacer
y decidí estudiar computación segundo
tienes que proponerte una gran meta
en mi caso ya les platiqué cuál era mi
sueño y qué pasó entre estos dos años y
medio de creer que era capaz de lograrlo
y realmente hacerlo a continuación se
los digo el paso número 3 es realmente
estudiar tu objetivo y aprender a decir
que no cuando estuve en el proceso de
tratar de entrar ahí me llegaron muchas
oportunidades profesionales que tuve que
rechazar algunas muy ambiciosas y que
dejaban mucho dinero por cierto pero
tuve que rechazarlas por por seguir
perseguir ese gran objetivo y como si
fuera un examen tienes que ponerte a
estudiar para saber qué necesitas
entonces dije a ver vamos a ver cuál es
el perfil de una empresa de una persona
que trabaja en esta empresa no me
investigando me di cuenta de varias
cosas número uno que tenían vasta
experiencia profesional yo me sentía la
gran cosa porque había ganado algunos
concursos pero no con experiencia
profesional así que dije pues voy a
trabajar también me di cuenta que otra
de las características en común era que
estas personas hablan varios idiomas no
yo apenas hablaba 2
voy a desarrollar mis yerros idiomas y
también me di cuenta que muchas de las
personas habían vivido trabajado en el
extranjero por mucho tiempo o por lo
menos un periodo así que dije voy a
viajar y me voy a ir de intercambios eso
se llaman micro metas son estos pequeños
escalones que te van llevando
paulatinamente a la cima y que te van a
llevar a cumplir ese gran objetivo
entonces de esta forma yo era un
estudiante que no generaba ingresos
entonces me puse a trabajar haciendo lo
que me gustaba empezar a desarrollar
aplicaciones móviles y con eso junté
dinero con ese dinero pues me fui de
viajes me fui de intercambio como cinco
veces y puede mejorar mis idiomas tu
regreso a mexico y las puertas de muchas
empresas ya estaban abiertas para mí
desarrollando mis idiomas y con más
experiencia en el extranjero así genera
experiencia laboral y cuando me sentí
listo vuelve a aplicar a la empresa y me
quedé suena muy fácil sin embargo es un
proceso de mucha disciplina y mucho
trabajo duro que todos tenemos que
conseguir entonces hay que repetir este
proceso muchas veces yo les vengo a
contar ahorita la historia de miel sobre
ojuelas en donde todo salió perfecto sin
embargo hubo muchos tropiezos y muchas
veces donde quise tirar la toalla
y dejar y abandonar mi sueño sin embargo
muchas veces tuve que volver a redefinir
mis micro metas para llegar a ese
objetivo porque no estaban funcionando
así que es bien importante
entonces cinco grandes pasos para lograr
tus objetivos en la vida no olvidemos
señor el señor es que este es un grafo
sí que tiene una estructura matemática
que si cumple con ciertas propiedades
científicas número uno el grafo de metas
es un grafo euler ya no recuerdan el
problema de los puentes pues el
científico llegó a la conclusión de que
no era posible cruzar los siete puentes
con yendo a la ciudad sin pasar más de
una vez por uno de ellos por la
configuración impar que tenía la ciudad
y los puentes utilizando esta
demostración matemática y un camino
bulería no por lo tanto es un camino en
el que pasas sin repetir alguno de los
de los caminos que te llevan a ella el
grafo de metas es un gran fútbol ya no
número dos el grafo de metas es un grafo
con nexo es decir para cualesquiera dos
vértices o puntitos que vemos en la
estructura hay un camino de aristas o
puentes que te pueden llevar uno a otro
y esa de ahí es la demostración
matemática qué significa eso que todas
las metas que tú conoces en la vida y
que llegas a cumplir están relacionadas
y todas las cosas que haces en la vida
te llevan a ser la persona que eres
y la ciencia lo demuestra
algo bien interesante es que cuando me
puse a hacer la demostración matemática
para ver qué funcionaba encontré que ese
camino euler ya no empezaba en él y
terminaba en b es decir empezaba con la
más pequeña de tus micro metas y
terminaba cuando cumples ese gran
objetivo
casualidad no lo creo es por eso que yo
les recomiendo que por más pequeño que
sea ese esfuerzo que van a hacer por
conseguir lo que quieren empiecen el día
de hoy y no crean que no va a servirles
porque eso es lo que nos hace día a día
las personas que somos entonces quiero
quiero terminar diciendo que lo más
bonito de las ciencias que tiene
aplicaciones en la vida real
y cuando cumples una gran meta pasas al
siguiente nivel como la regla del medio
maratón o donde una persona quería
correr un maratón pero primero tenían
que correr medio maratón y primero tenía
que correr 10 kilómetros y antes de este
único 45 y conforme lo iban logrando ya
no le costaba trabajo correr 5 10 15 y
eventualmente ya me costaba trabajo
correr un maratón corría 2 al año 3 al
año de esa forma cuando trabajas por tus
objetivos
alcanzas un gran una gran meta eres
capaz de hacer cosas aún más
extraordinarias y de manera análoga el
grafo de meta se conecta de forma tal
que te permite seguir escalando y llegar
aún más lejos tal y como rey dalo en su
libro principios indica en la vida
siempre tenemos nos vamos a contar con
problemas y tenemos metas no de dónde
nos encontramos problemas y
eventualmente fallamos pero lo
interesante es aprender de esos errores
mejorar y pasar al siguiente nivel para
cumplir ese objetivo
y a mí me pasó una vez que logras esto
llegas al siguiente nivel que es va
generando una cadena de valor que te
permite ir por metas aún más ambiciosos
de lo que tú creías siempre y cuando tú
creas que eres capaz de poder hacer eso
que siempre quisiste entonces al día de
hoy yo quiero invitarte a ti a que
salgas de estas a la lucha por alcanzar
eso que siempre quisiste y creíste que
no eras capaz de lograr y de esta forma
transformar muchos no en sí muchas
gracias